um do
folks there stand stand
foration you know which one oh person
what what is
this what's going the first that's right
and then what is Association stand
for I believe this is
M yeah who started sale I if I
understand correctly is that right he
started
sale yeah I think he I think he did but
anyways uh so so so what's interesting
is so it's it's it's it's it's it's
amusing to actually look at uh what they
what they wrote in their um I don't know
was a brochure what they wrote in their
their goals right so so so phont is a
bit small okay so so this the study is
to Pro on the basis of the conjecture
that every aspect of learning or any
other feature of uh of intelligence can
principle be principle be so precisely
describe that a machine can be made to
simulate it right fantastic so single
machine you want to simulate all of like
human intelligence okay and a carefully
selected group of scientists uh and and
we think that we can make uh actually
the paragraph right before the second uh
set of uh uh uh red underline is uh we
think that a significant Advance can be
made in one in one or two of these
problems if uh if um a carefully
selective group of scientists work on
together for a summer okay uh I don't
think they knew of AI Winters then
actually they didn't know of it then but
and and and and and the third third
thing uh is amusing is but the major
obstacle is not lack of machine capacity
uh but our inability to write programs
taking full advantage of what we have so
so so while the goals are noble it's
surprising how wrong you can be in in
with some of the smartest people in in
the room right so uh self uh and neuron
Network oi that were the originally were
pandemonium I think he got everything
basically except PA problems in Black
boox optimization then uh mitsky of
course Shannon uh salmanov I think this
salmanov mdl uh you know in many ways
you can argue that's that that's the
underpinning of of of uh of unsup of of
self-supervised learning today but but
it's really amusing to see to see the
first VI I mean at least I don't know if
we'll be able if you'll be able to
characterize uh uh characterize uh or
write down all the rules for
intelligence so you can imagine that the
approaches they were taking were all
these rule based systems right um and
and they couldn't be more wrong on
machine capacity uh uh today's
Transformers are they don't they're data
centers right and uh I and I
guess the the they needed a really
really long summer to solve this one but
uh yeah so so so so uh so it's 1955 so
so so like about uh yeah 60 60 years uh
no no not getting close to 70 70 years
right so and and and we're we're
basically talking about the same
problems again except maybe except maybe
some things work some things don't work
and and and and this talk is about like
uh you know some of the one of the one
of the pieces that has made this larger
Enterprise work and then and and we
getting closer to the original the
original goals of the of the Dartmouth
conference yeah uh again okay so so so
so so this is like the big gaps I mean
so what what eventually happened in the
field was that you know their goal of
having a single system that explained
most of um that was able to mimic our
cognitive abilities which would
definitely mean like image processing or
image understanding and language
processing as well right that that I
mean the field got mean a single a
single model or a single approach to do
all these things was shattered by like
thousands of like different research
projects soan I mean there was no
consolidation but here's another here's
another here's another uh this is going
to be a harder one uh can you tell where
is the this is this is 2009 and this is
a this is not a single system this is a
complicated machine translation system
so when I started my phdr machine transl
systems used to be a bit more
complicated complicated than this
actually thousands of pipeline systems
uh you had to First extract you had to
First do word alignments that actually
looked like attention it's like hard you
think about it as hard attention then
based on that we extract like how larger
phrases aligned with other phrases then
you had to figure out how how they then
had then you had to teach there was some
machine learning there you had to teach
a model how to score them connecting
with each other so can you can you does
anybody know where a Neal network is in
this all right so CS so this is the uh
this is a machine translation system
from 2009 and cslm is a continuous State
Lang language model that's there used
for rescoring right so the world was so
discreet then that he had to call these
models like continuous State language
models and and I mean it was it was
largely inspired by the neuro
probabilistic language model by oh it
doesn't
appear
huh
sorry ah there the the the neuro
probabilistic language model by by by
benju I think was in fil tree and and
and so we were um even even in in 2013
when I when I when I when I published a
paper on neur language models these mod
these models were still being put into
the fe4 neural network language models
were still you know be scoring and now
it's it's incredible if you think about
it like so just in terms of
consolidation how all of these
complicated systems that have now been
replaced by just neurons that talk to
each other and you just learn the rules
from you just learn the rules from data
automatically so so so so so so it's
it's fun to
it's it's it's it's interesting to see
and and and so and since then you know
like so this is this is what the emlp
2013 conference was like you see these
different uh like these these these you
can call it verticalized NLP these
different areas like morphology dialogue
and discourse I mean I don't even know
if people talk about dialogue and
discourse just talk to models no there's
no I don't know if there's a research
fact anymore then there is like a
machine translation so like this opinion
mining andc sentiment analysis
uh now models make you angry or or upset
so it's it's and and so so you could see
that just in 2013 the the field even
research was divided into these smaller
tracks and everybody had their own
specific they were bringing their own
specific um domain domain information
and they had to specialize in a domain
in order to solve some tasks and we
solve tasks to some degree machine
translation because I mean probably
because of of a lot of government
funding as well we had made a lot of
progress and you were making practical
translations systems that were being
being deployed in the wild Google
translate was a great example of that
right and and and and and so since then
you like you we had this you know we we
we started to uh through first first we
all agreed we need distributed we need
distributed word representations and you
saw this like people probably remember
this funky uh this funky uh embedding
algebra King minus man plus woman equals
equals Queen from from WC um and uh and
we had a we had a there was a there was
a there was a big industry of of models
uh that that actually that just that
that learned word representations and
the word representations were actually
useful in Downstream tasks and then then
came like you know another step in this
process another step in this process
where now we started saying okay these
representations like in there're but
they're they're they're only helpful if
they're learned in context right so the
king should change uh based on context
right uh the the the the king of of
Persia or the the King has no clothes or
the emperor has no clothes right uh and
and and so so so that so we we saw these
we saw approaches like sequence to
sequence sequence learning where we
started to like formulate we started to
create these general formulations of how
to solve any task in NLP right so
sequence to sequence formulation if you
can you can you can you can you can
formulate many tasks in language of
sequence to sequence question answering
machine translation dialogue so and then
and and and and then of course we had
then we then we developed attention
right which was a which was a very
effective content based way to summarize
information if you were typically you
have these encoder decoder architectures
everybody is probably I'm guessing
familiar with encoder decoder
architectures right so encoder decoder
architecture and a and a and and and a
position on the decoder side could
summarize based on its content all the
information on the in the source
sentence right and this was really
effective content based way of
summarizing information and and and what
what started happening was we started
these these General uh these General
paradigms started started coming up
sequence to sequence learning can solve
if it can solve most language problems
because most language problems have to
deal with learning representations of
variable length the the goal is to learn
representations of variable length
sequences and if you do that
successfully you can then potentially
solve that problem and then attention
was an excellent way a Content based way
to actually summarize information from
some neighborhood and um and and and and
so so so so and the and the major
workart until then were these recurrent
models or lstms right uh where basically
uh the the the the method was typically
the same you had a you had a sentence
and you crushed the sentence into into a
set of into a set of vectors set of
representations one typically typically
one for each position right and the way
lstms did it was where they walked along
the sentence they ate up a word and then
they summarized they summarized the
entire history into one fixed bottleneck
and that bottleneck was then transmitted
was updated based on the next words so
so so now and and and and and if if you
were successfully able to learn
representations then we could solve
these tasks like translation
summarization dialogue so it's an
important movement and and and like 2020
I I 20 I guess when was the sequence to
sequence learning papers 2015 neps then
we saw then we saw the attention paper
in around 2015 2016 and the Machine
translation Community was kind of the
first to respond and say hey uh you know
machine translations is a classic
sequence to sequence learning problem
like why don't we now first start
rescoring and then can we still build
native greeny rethink machine
translation with these sequence to
sequence models right um and and these
are fantastic models I don't know if you
guys have ever done these exercises on
lstms can can count like if if you for
example if you if you train an encoder
decoder on if you like on to Model A to
the nend B to the end so you feed in Nas
and you ask the decoder to predict n uh
NBS and you actually just a single cell
lstm if you know the structure of an LSM
there's a cell that basically keeps so
it's it's a notion of state and just a
single cell is able to actually just do
trivial counting it's it counts how many
A's where you you consumed and then it
decrements it and then when you consume
all the exactly the same number of B's
is the number of A's uh something like
something and says I'm done I've
recognized this language so you can TR
Tri like a to the end B to the end and
here you have you have a I'm sorry this
this is not clear but you have somewhat
of a you have a grammar here and you can
see that these are different cells this
the eight cells here and each one of
these cells actually increments its
counter once it reads a particular
symbol and it's able to actually track
how deep you are in this how deep you
are in this hierarchy in this grammar
and uh and Google and Google of course
um the the crowning achievement perhaps
of sequence to sequence models which uh
I was actually right I I had I was
fortunate to to be in the the same
cuticle as it was being as work was
being done was the Google Ur machine
translation system where they took LSM I
mean they added they added many
advancements of course a lot of systems
improvements a lot of a lot of data that
Google had and they produced what you
might at that at that time the
state-ofthe-art ne machine translation
system sequence to sequence models so
now this big Consolidated this big
complicated system which looked much
which looked much more complicated and
now become a homogeneous just as a
single homogeneous neuron Network right
um so at the time the the biggest
frustration we had was this was I mean
these the lstms of the primary Workforce
and and the biggest the biggest
frustration they had was they they I
mean not only were were we producing uh
not not only were we did we produce the
output Auto aggressively we were
sequentially decoding the output left or
right but also we were reading the input
sequentially so you had to kind of in
order to produce that in order to
produce the representation for the 10th
word you had to eat up you have to the
first word the second word the third
word so that was that was really slow
and and and and and and and and and and
not the whole the and another big
problem with lstms were that you have
this bottom lck that basically that
contains all the information about your
past so you have to now you have to now
Crush you have to you have to pack both
long distance interactions that you
might have and local interactions
through the single single fixed factor
that you need to transmit right and and
sequentiality uh it doesn't inhibits
parallelism which means that you
couldn't even read like The encoder
couldn't even read the sentence in
parallel and of course decoding was Auto
regressive so you couldn't even write in
parallel right um and and um
convolutions were they were starting to
emerge as a solution largely I mean they
had been very successful in in they had
been very successful in computer vision
they had also figured out how to
optimize them well how to make them how
how to train how how to make them really
fast on on on gpus where and because
they're they're just basically Matrix
multiplications and matrix
multiplication is largely is paralyzable
um so convolutions were were were were
were a solution to this to this problem
of of not being able to to read in
parallel right because you could in
parallel every word could basically
produce its representation by looking at
its neighbor by looking at its neighbors
right its local its local neighbors and
uh there were there there were some very
very like there were some breakthrough
papers such as bitet uh for machine
translation uh the convolutional
sequence to sequence model that was
called temus to the Transformer actually
probably predated by a few months where
they used where they Ed convolutions
both on the incoder and decoder to to uh
get good scores on machine translation
that that were better than the Google
neur machine translation system and of
course probably the most successful the
most successful of uh the the most
successful was wavenet which was a text
to speech system that was
state-of-the-art at the time um and
again so so so so so this so convolution
still had this problem that one I guess
they were paralyzable but the issue was
that you you still you couldn't directly
capture long distance interactions
between you you D couldn't directly
between words right so if you're
basically a receptive field if it's like
a like a 3X3 if it's a if it's a it's a
1 by3 then it basically grows linearly
with the factor of it grows linearly
with with the number of with the number
of layers each time each time it expands
by three so so so you you still needed a
a linear number of layers to capture
these long-distance relationships uh and
and but attention on the other hand was
this really effective mechanism that we
knew was that that that could
actually get us in in one it it could
actually capture all the interactions
between one word and every other
word using using content based
addressing right because convolutions
basically match convolutions match
weights with parameters attention they
actually able to use content with
content So based on how similar I am to
my neighborhood based on how how similar
I to my neighbors I'm going to absorb
that information and this actually this
Motif actually appears everywhere even
in computer even in computer vision so
uh maybe actually I can go there so so
here here's a here's a in in in Vision
there's this there's this approach do
people here know of non non loal
means so in in computer vision there's a
there's an approach called non-local
means that's basically uh it was
originally developed for image Den
noising so if you want to denoise an
image patch you basic you looked at all
your neighbors and you see which patch
is very similar to you and based on the
similarity you actually pulled in that
information so and and and and this
largely work in images because images
are very self self similar this start
sounding like hey based on content I
want to pull in information and and
again they they were similar there were
approaches like uh uh texture synthesis
by EOS where if you wanted to if you
wanted to do kind of painting or if you
wanted to generate an image then you
would look at a patch that's similar to
this rectangle in some other in your in
your dictionary or in like a database
that you have of patches and then based
on what's closest to you actually bring
it right so you you you'll bring that
patch and then you'll paste it there so
so these approaches that look like
attention were already were already
prevalent it's a very natural
formulation and it's and and and and and
and and and and the the the bad paper
had had shown that this actually works
really well for language as well so so
the question then was okay why can't we
then learn representations instead of
doing this Source Target why can't we
actually learn representations by by the
sentence attending onto itself so now
you you basically use you you instead of
attending a source sentence attending to
a Target sentence can of just attend to
itself
and the original goal of actually when
we wanted when we when we we wanted to
actually do parallel decoding so um so
attention by construction is paralyzable
because each each uh each token can
basically construct its representations
from its neighbors in parallel right and
uh it directly captures token to token
interactions because no of course we'll
run into complexities of complexities of
length but we can we can disc and we'll
discuss our Sol some some of these
things later or to overcome them but you
can direct instead of having this sort
of linear growth in receptive field you
can directly capture these interactions
because convolutions if you have a very
very large receptor field it gets
computationally very expensive and it
also had these explicit gating and
multiplicative interactions which we've
often seen like in gated pixel CNN or G
they see this these they the these G
explicit gated multiplicative
interactions have typically helped
training and have led to better better
better accuracies um and the as I
mentioned the original motivation of why
we actually wanted to do this was we
said Hey Okay so the lstms are are you
have good translation systems but the
problem is that actually both reading
and writing uh sequentially can we
actually do both in parallel so we
wanted to read we wanted to read like we
wanted to read the German sentence in
parallel and then translate it in and
then also write in parallel by that
instead of actually decoding it sort of
Auto regressively can you decode it
instead of decoding in time can you
decode it in in height so like you first
first spit out one word or you spit out
all the words and you iteratively refine
them right and uh this was a this turned
out to be very very challenging and
hasn't been solved successfully until
today because the biggest challenge
essentially is when you whenever you're
decoding right essentially as you
predict a word you kind of bend the
probability distribution that then nails
down Narrows down what you're going to
predict later on and the and and and the
ordering that allows you basically the
ordering that allows you to nail these
modes was very hard to learn so imposing
Left Right ordering is much easier than
actually not having one and having to
learn it as you're as you're decoding so
we the original approaches didn't work
but then we we still had we still had um
we still had our Salvation in being able
to read parall so we said all right
let's take this back to the encoder
decoder models and and uh and and unlike
at that time there were a few
formulations right so we had the sort of
the original formulation attention from
graves then we have the additive
attention formulation and uh we took the
and we took the dot product uh attention
formulation largely because it allowed
us to do uh it because it allowed us to
actually do attention as a matrix
multiplication and and often times some
of the biggest constraints that actually
physics is such a big constraint in
neuron networks that if you can if you
can make your if you can make your
architecture amenable to to Modern
accelerators you have a much better
chance you have a much better chance of
succeeding and and Dot product attention
could be expressed as a multiplication
and it's and and and they're already sub
they're already kernels for for for
being able to do matrix multiplication
very effectively on the GPU so we had so
so the formulation was all right so so
now we have similar to The Dot product
detention we had a scaling Factor simply
because if the if the dot product
actually becomes too big and you can
solve it under certain assumptions of
mean and variance in the in the in the
representations you can hasn't updated
actually yeah so so Bas so so our
formulation is basically you have you
have uh uh your queries uh which uh what
you what you end up doing is if you have
a if you have a position you first
projected into queries um and then the
same the same token the same the
representation of the same token gets
projected into to also keys and values
and the first uh the query determines
how much in how much you're actually
going to pull from all these keys so you
first do a DOT product of the query with
every key and then based on that you you
combine or you pull the content of in
all these positions based on uh based on
what the based on what the score was
after after normalizing it using a soft
Max so in some sense you can think of
self attention also as kind of a Content
based pooling mechanism right and the
scaling Factor basically avoids you
avoids you uh like it saved us from
these low jits actually blowing up and
training become becoming unstable and on
the decoder side uh you could trivially
you can trivially Implement uh causality
by just adding an adding an attention
adding an attention mask um and what
this where this where this brings us is
that all right so so now we've we've
solved now uh there's it's so a caveat
on the flops we'll actually cover this
later but now what we have is a
mechanism that that's paralyzable it
gives you direct uh uh it gives you
direct content cont it gives you direct
token interactions it and that that we
that we that we believe is going to help
you actually learn model these
relationships between the words better
and it's and it's and the complexity of
self attention is FAS than convolutions
right because because convolutions are
quadratic in the number they're
quadratic in the number of channels in
the number of in the hidden Dimension
but a self attention is quadratic in the
length so if your length is not much
more than a hidden Dimension you've
actually saved down flops now this is a
not not quite a complete picture because
not all flops are equal and we'll talk
about this later on
um and and and and and now when you
putting when you put everything together
what we what basically we we kind of
took the the the basis
this has a very strong uh similarity to
the to the resonet architecture actually
so if we look at resonet right so in
resets you have contraction you have
spatial mixing with convolutions and
then you have the expansion again right
if you just with the Transformer if you
just adjust if you just move it one one
step down it's very it's analogous you
have you have a tension then you have
expansion contraction but there a and
difference in where the residual
connections are but it's a it's a very
similar it's a very similar sort of
basic building block with say the resid
with the residual connection and you
have these contractions and expansions
and in the Transformer those were that
was multi-head attention with expansion
contraction which was in the feet
forward layers and and and then uh one
one one challenge with the tension we Lo
lstms can count they can impact they can
they can they can they can count they
can uh learn interesting temporal
patterns but
uh attention is permutation inance so we
had to actually add position we had to
add position information so that we
could we could learn ordering so we add
position information at the input which
trans gets transmitted to the other
layers through uh through the through
the through the residual connections and
uh the original paper we had the we had
post layer Norm but later on we realized
that as we actually make the model
deeper post laym is doesn't doesn't
allow you to train effectively so we had
to then we then we used a pre- layer
Norm formulation which was also observed
in the original reset papers and um so
the model is basically all right you got
your input well you have spatial mixing
spatial mixing to attention feed forward
layers and this sort of repeats and the
uh the the difference in on the decoder
side is that you also now have encoder
decoder attention and encoder decoder
attention uh at every at every uh at
every
layer if there's any questions yeah yes
what was your
behind oh so so it end up so if you do
Post layer Norm then then uh actually
let uh is do I have that slide let me
check probably would have deleted but if
you do Post layer Norm then you are
basically squashing both the residual
and the additive parts so when you so
your activations from the lower layers
keep getting keep going through a layer
Norms but in pre- layer Norm you're only
only a residual path has a layer Norm
which means your your activations all
the way from the bottom of the model are
free they're untouched and they can pass
through
yeah um
okay okay so now so now I mean so until
this point we haven't discussed why did
we you know we haven't discussed multi
had the tension which ended up being
very important so one of the problems
with the tension is that
imagine if you wanted to yeah I mean so
oftentimes language is a better
understanding who did what to whom so in
this case the the the cat licked the
owner's hand so licked who licked what
like the cat licked the owner right so
now if you actually want to combine
information from these two slots these
positions these vectors then the best
you could do with the tension is 0.5
point5 with a single lay right half
probability half probability but then
they get mushed together right but now
imagine the imagine the strength that a
convolution has it can actually have
uh that actually should have well okay
well I think the point will still come
across but uh so now what a convolution
can do is because it has it it basically
applies essentially a convolution in
this case it's a 5 by one it all it
really does is it just applies a
different linear transformation at each
position right so it can take any and
because because these linear
Transformations are different it can it
can the first linear transformation can
learn I'm going to take a little bit of
information from here I'm going to take
a little bit of information from here
and I'm going to like put them together
right and and and and the attention the
best way that you could actually just do
this is best by averaging that would bu
all these things but having different
linear Transformations allows you to
take a part of the embedding here a part
of the embedding here mix it up and then
sort of maybe put it together without
actually then interfering with each
other and multi-head attention which is
a bit like basically a multi-tape
multi-ad
like multi-ad turning machine with
different different readed right heads
essentially allows you start getting you
that property back where now what you do
is you essentially you essent you you
you now you bring back the ability to
select different parts of the input so
you chop up the hidden Dimension into
independent pieces and then each one of
them is not is now able to do attention
so now you can have probability one in
this place and what probability one this
other Subspace instead of having. 5.5 so
now you don't you don't have to like you
don't have to get these averaging
effects you can actually be selective
right so so so and and and and and also
for computational reasons we instead of
actually having eight attention layers
of like or six attention heads of D
Dimensions we had or eight attention
heads of D Dimensions we had eight
attention heads of D by8 Dimensions
right so and and and and because so we
wouldn't incur anymore we wouldn't incur
any more um uh any more flops for the
same amount of flops but that's only
half the story because the attention
heads themselves turn out to be quite
expensive which which then later on had
to be there were the improvements that
needed to be made right um uh and and
and and the most important part probably
the most important results was that with
the Transformer we were we were able to
outperform previous previous ensembled
models as well so and that was very very
exciting that hey this single model
actually is able to outperform previous
ensembled models and and not only that
and and this is machine translation WMT
uh uh um 2014 English German and English
French machine translation tasks not and
not only were we able to do it in in in
less in in in less flops but also these
like if it was very it was it was very
clear that this was this was a very
general model is it we immediately
applied it to parsing and we were able
to get we were able to get with a small
model excellent excellent results so so
um and in some sense like you know we
were this was this was very exciting
because this meant that all right now
this consolidation that we're trying to
go for the machine learning we probably
have a model that's more General than
what we had before and we we can now
throw it at different now maybe we can
now throw it at different problems right
and ultimately why
because it would
be helpful to have a single model that's
able to combine representations from
speech images and and and language and
and if you had a general substrate that
worked work and worked well in all tasks
then potentially we could get to this
single multimodal model um as as U
sometimes interpretability are like like
tea leaves uh it's like reading tea
leaves so so so everyone should be
careful but it was it was nice that you
know the the attention by itself can can
give you some interpretability and we
were able to kind of see how you know
how some some of these attention heads
or some of these attentions attention
mechanisms uh were actually able to
learn long-distance relationships some
actually learned to be kind of early on
early on in the Transformer uh we saw
this generally invariant pattern where
some of the attention heads basically
turned out to just look like
convolutions they were just they were
just pulling in local information
there's of course now being much more
advanced work with the some of the
mechanistic interpretability stuff with
uh with grocking and the stuff that
that's happening in anthropic uh which
is where they're learning now they're
actually learning uh how how to
interpret these induction heads so it's
interesting but we were able to we were
able to see some some anecdotal
evidences evidence of these heads
actually performing very very distinct
and clear actions um okay so if there's
any more questions then no more uh I'll
pause
do you buy the research on like that
it's the induction heads that are
causing the in context
learning yeah it's hard to tell because
so from what I haven't looked at the
most recent work but they've solved this
issue of superposition is that right so
now with having solved that they're able
to roughly does that roughly mean that
now they they'll be able to assign
distinguishing features to each one of
these heads and be able to explain it I
I I I I from what I understand or or or
the in context learning part is is that
uh is it that they have to show it or is
it that they're saying that in context
Learning Happens because of induction
yeah the l oh it's the L yeah I it's not
it's not clear because
um yeah I think there's probably many
many kinds of in context learning is
shown to work in so many different tasks
that uh and I actually I haven't
followed this quite well I don't know I
don't know specifically what are the
induction heads typically do what kinds
of What kinds of properties do they have
what do you know what kinds of
mechanisms they have okay so yeah so
then so so since both of us don't know
this really really well uh uh I we won't
be able to go very far here but uh I I I
I I'm not sure if they've gotten to the
point where they're able to explain most
of in context learning because of
induction from what I understand they
might have yeah does anybody anybody
know about the induction
heads okay
um okay so so so now um over the over
over the years um so there there have
been a few there have been many papers
but there have been a few changes that
have been important there have been a
few changes that that that that have
stuck and and the new Transformers
typically have these typically have
these improvements right and and and you
we'll go from bottom to top with some of
them and see which ones which ones have
actually stuck right so we started with
the first one of the biggest problems
with self attention was that it was uh
that self attention itself this
permutation invariant right you you you
need to you need to you need to you need
to dope position information in order
for it to learn some kind of temporal
temporal structure and in the original
Transformer we used these sinusoids and
we had hoped that it would actually
learn relative position and codings
because you could decompose the position
and coding of another of another of you
could you could decompose the position
embedding of another position as some
fun as some linear function of the
previous one and we and and some and
another
uh another factor which is which depends
on the relative distance between the two
but that didn't happen uh learn position
en codings in the original paper
uh did as well and uh so so we were not
quite able to get the the we were not
quite able to get these model relative
distances using the sinusoids so then uh
a couple of you know a couple of
important and this is a very biased
sample uh but I think it generally
covers a large category of these uh uh
it covers large large set of papers
there's roughly sort of three categories
right so there's um and and all of them
are kind of now explicitly learning
relative uh explicitly learning relative
embedding so so there's so so in in the
in the relative position Transformer we
had an embedding for every pair of
relative positions and using that we
basically then dot we did a DOT product
of that embedding with the query that
produced a loit that was that modulated
according to the relative distance and
we found this to be extremely uh we
found this to be uh extremely useful for
translation but and I'll show also music
um another another sort of maybe a
simplification uh This Is The Alibi
paper where this is nonparametric these
are not learned where instead of an
embeding for every pair of positions you
actually have a single bias right so you
you so you just add a single bias to the
login and you can either learn it or you
can you can or or you can use a
heuristic which which Alibi did and one
one other Advantage about relative
position en codings is that they could
potentially allow you to extrapolate to
new to longer sequence length right
which you couldn't do with absolute
position and codings
um I'm curious about the room about what
the room thinks here but I believe that
the the latest the the the latest
Incarnation Val position and codings
where this is I believe it's called the
the row forer where they basically just
you know rotate the embedding of with
every pair of dimensions a little bit so
and and the and the and the angle of
rotation depends on on your actual
absolute distance but what ends up
happening is when you when you do the
attension operation you end up getting
relative uh you end up basically getting
an effect where you're modulating the
ljit based on relative distance so now
what's remarkable about this approach
what's what's it combines the best of
both rols right it actually it's
absolute position in codings uh relative
position encodings had a couple of
challenges in that they you had to
maintain an extra lit for or an
embedding for every pair so there was a
lot of me so it ended up increasing your
memory uh here these are actually
absolute position encodings but they
gave you they ended up giving you the
the relative modulation in the in the
attention operation that you needed and
I I believe the consensus is that this
is the most successful this is the most
successful position in coding is that
correct or are there is there are there
others that are the people is is that
the
consensus okay so so it looks like so I
I I would say that the the the the the
the these relative rotations or from or
the the approach that's in the reformer
is is is likely is is basically an
actual new genuine Improvement that is
now going to stay with the Transformer
and and it has all the it has all the
great properties of what you would want
it it's it has it's an absolute position
in quoting that gives you relative
effects which is what we originally
wanted um and and and one and and and to
emphasize emphasize that we needed
relative like um that
U being uh emphasize two things one that
modeling temp like interesting temporal
relationships which is which are really
important in music uh requires a good
position representation uh we actually
found significant improvements in the
music Transformer is it is it possible
to play this okay so so so here is a um
here's a priming sequence this is this
is work by by work by Anna hang by the
way
so this is a in context learn in music
because you actually see this prompt and
you ask the model to complete it uh okay
so now this is the vanilla Transformer
and you can
already so you can see that uh these
these were using I mean we tried both
learned and sinusoids and you can see
that it starts all all py and happy but
then just sort of languishes into
something really sad and and and
confused right so it's not able to
capture these because mus music has
these interesting motifs where well
there's there's there's motifs at
different levels because you know
there's some repetition locally but
there's a repetition across the entire
piece as well so now here this is with
the uh uh relative Transformer and and
this is with the uh first approach where
we had relative embeddings and we had to
we had to we had to develop a an a
compute efficient approach to actually
with by using some Matrix uh
calisthenics to actually put the loits
in the right place so you can read the
papers it's fun uh so here's same Prime
sequence and uh let's see the
completion
here
so Anna who's the first author of this
paper and also musician tells me this
actually captures a lot of structure in
music I I uh it sounds nicer than the
previous one but maybe depends on what
people's tastes here like maybe some
avangard jazz fan would like the second
would like the first piece but but but
but the the point here was that like the
difference is pretty clear between not
working and working and I I think people
it would be fun to try this out with the
with the new rotary position en
codings all right um okay so so so so so
walking up um now that we have a we have
a good mechan a better mechanism than we
originally had for modeling relative
distances and and and and and and
there's there's there's advancements on
top of the rotary position en codings
where by adjusting the base frequencies
you can you can when you when you
encounter longer sequences you can just
adjust the base frequencies and then the
model is not going to uh
uh the model is not going to degrade so
that that has good properties uh
probably the the there's been there have
been several several important uh uh
contributions to to the attention piece
itself which which is which is the
primary Workhorse here it's the it's the
one that you can think of it as it's
either it's it's it's um it's there's
induction heads that are learning how to
coffee or maybe all it's really doing is
just routing information so that the
giant feed forward layers can actually
learn the important features right but
there's brly two classes of problems
there are two classes of issues uh with
the attention mechanism one that was
brought up today that's very evident is
is long context itself right so so uh
the the the complexity as we remember
was quadratic in the length of the
sequence and once your sequences get
very very long once your sequences get
very very long then uh uh not only I
mean there's there's one problem is
going to it's going to become very it's
going to become computationally
expensive but it's also the logits that
are going to become infusible right so
there's sort of just generally like a
few groups of papers one is restricting
attention windows and we did this for
images images where they had local 1D
and and 2D uh 2D attention for images
and the first in the first one we
actually just rasterized the image and
we had local 1D attention which is very
similar to the sliding window attention
in uh in the in the recent nostal paper
and then in the
uh uh and in the um in the 2D case we
have a spal 2d uh spatial to attention
right then there's these sparse versions
where you actually you you have these
specific patterns that over many layers
I mean you can think about it as if you
have these sparse matrices how many of
them do you have to multiply with each
other until until you get a really dense
Matrix right so roughly this kind of
turns out to be so here you can get
connectivity except for
me okay uh uh uh um you can you can get
connectivity you can get connectivity
between distant pixels distant pixels or
distant uh notes in a in in in a musical
tune or words pretty quickly uh and then
there's a second one which I which is
which there hasn't been enough work and
there there's there's some challenges
there but it's it's these unstructured
sparse attention approaches and they're
typically they're essentially what
they're at a higher level what they're
really trying to do is imagine that I
walked up to you and I told you that hey
these These are the Bunches of um of
tokens that just have very high inter
similarity like they're likely to attend
to each other how quickly can I approxim
without actually having to do the whole
computation right two approaches and and
routing attention you use vector
quantization and in in the L or
the I forget what it's called I think I
forget the name of the paper but they Ed
but in this paper they used lsh and um
and and and in the in the in the routing
Transformer most layers were actually
local uh the the final layers which
typically are the ones that like to end
up that end up do modeling that end up
modeling these long distance
relationships were the ones that
actually use this kind of content based
unstructured sparse attention and uh and
the results were the results were
generally better and it's also
interesting that maybe we can build we
can build models but very on very long
sequen sequences where most layers are
fairly local and have only a few there
that are actually doing these long
distance attentions now one of the
bigger challenges there actually even
though it ended up being even though you
end up um you end up nullifying a lot of
the flops that you would do if you did
full attention the problem always ends
up being memory movement always ends up
being memory movement and and and and
there's still there's still more
Innovation to be done here also with
like memory bandwidth improving maybe
some of these approaches become more
feasible today than than they were when
we did when we wrote these papers but
this is an interesting approach where
you're kind of essentially trying to
approximate the original attention
Matrix sorry this is kind of
clarification how is
thisr scheme very different from like
just convolutions that are in the sense
that you're losing a lot of the long
distance or unrelated context from any
arbitrary compar elements so right so I
would say that this is similar to the
convolution there if you did this
perfectly then what you didn't attend to
would wouldn't would like very likely
that has very low attention we s so
that's you're essentially trying to
you're essentially trying to guess as
best as you can what would have attended
to each other and that's and so it uses
it's content based like content based on
structured farity um and and and there's
probably more interesting work to be
done there maybe you know instead of
actually just doing a token at a time
where you end up doing a lot of memory
movement you end up deciding which
chunks want to self attend to which
chunks so then you just move in pair
chunks at a time right so there's I
think there's some interesting
directions here um and of course um and
and and frankly um the the ones that
ended up sing out the simplest ones that
are also that are and because structured
scarcity is easy you're you're able to
optimize it easy easily on Modern
accelerators so again physics uh you
should make physics your friend yeah and
and and so typically local attention or
sliding into attention we're still
seeing we're still seeing it often
appear and do well uh these other sort
of very really wild and uh but very
expressive unstructured SPS attention
approaches typically Haven haven't quite
succeeded uh there's of course linear
attention variants that I don't think
today are in any of the state are
architectures there were other
approaches that hey instead of actually
doing N squared you do uh n squar d
where you you do n you have some you you
you learn new K embeddings where you do
nkd and then you do ndk so you basically
Factor it right just like like an analog
matric factorization something that's
one other approach that's interesting
that I would like myself to actually
invest investigate is we are seeing in
general using retrieval as a tool so why
don't you just pretend that your
memories your memories themselves were
documents and use retrieval as a tool
there so the memorizing Transformer uh
basically it essentially does a mix of
local and it then retrieves from very
very long very very long memories and
they find that you don't need to train
the model from scratch all you need to
do is adapt with this approach uh on on
on some a small amount of data and
you're able to learn a good retrieval
mechanism I think it's quite interesting
it it kind of it still kind of comes in
this like uh content based R content
based decision of what I should attempt
to but I I like the fact that it it's it
just sort of makes retrieval a tool that
you can use on either on your own
memories or you could use it on
documents it's it's it's a nice
generalizing it's a nice General view of
looking at things um okay so now the
second piece which which not you you you
basically you run into not all you run
into the issue that not all flops are
equal right so if you um if you look at
the if if you look at the memory
hierarchy right a lot of your
activations and that are stored in the
the GPU hbm which today in the h100 is
about is about 80 gigabytes but you know
um the the the H1 h100 is 80 gigabytes
when the a100 is used to be 40 gigabytes
right so it's limited amount of of high
bandwith memory and and so you have to
first go from high bandwith memory to to
the SRAM and then you have to go to the
computer elements and then back right so
every single time and this is I mean
it it it probably uh in you know
whenever if if if interested you should
look at roof Lan analysis the roofline
analysis actually gives you a uh gives
you a nice picture to characterize for
any device you know what uh where you
would need where your your workload or
operation needs to be so that you can
actually effectively utilize the compute
as much you want to be compute bound
because ultimately if you don't
calculate representations if you don't
calculate you're not going to get any
outputs but if you spend a lot of time
moving things around and spend less
relative time calculating then you're
then you're then you're actually you're
you're kind of wasting effort right so
so so one of the so if you at standard
attention mechanism right one of the
issues is that okay so imagine you have
your queries keys and values all in your
all in your memory then you need to then
uh your standard approach would be you
move it you move it from hbm you do the
calculations you compute the attention
you compute the logits you move logits
back into HPM and then you can get
softmax right the softmax back into HPM
and and then you basically load uh the
the probabilities uh and and the values
then to then finally compute the outputs
right so the the arithmetic intensity or
the arithmetic intensity or operational
intensity which is the amount of flops
that you do per bite on a tension even
though it's less flops than say a 1 by
one convolution it it has more it is
lower because it typically has more
memory movement as one by one
convolutions have less memory movement
you just move the weights you move the
activations you do the calculations and
you bring them back right and same goes
for convolutions too and convolutions
have a very high arithmetic intensity
it's not that you just want the highest
arithmetic intensity or operational
intensity operations because you still
want to have useful parameters right so
it's a trade-off so so so so a lot of so
there's been a bunch of improvements
that will stick I mean there it's almost
almost certain likely to stay that that
try to combat this issue both at
training time because your Logics can
get really big but also inference time
your KV when you're when you're when
you're doing attention when you're doing
inference then you have a single query
but your KV cash right you have to to
maintain your keys and values that can
grow quite a bit so you have to move
that around and so the first the the
first step is hey simple let's just
decrease the activation memory so so the
so the multiquery approach where it's
basically uh you know multiple so you
reduce you you have multiple queries
with just you reduce the number of uh
read heads uh to just one so just one p
and one value that does reduce your
expressivity so grouped query which is
now a simp like simple balance that
basically says hey let's not take the
extreme of having all this temporary
activation memory let's actually group
it so different queries so a bunch of
queries will attend to the same keys and
values and and then what what it ends up
happening is um another point to note
here is that all of this is relative
because most of the work in these very
very oh by the third approach actually
that I should say of uh of not worrying
about your attention is just to make
your model really B because then you
just care about your feet forward
computations and your attention
computations this like a small slice of
that so you don't worry about it right
so typically these larger models even
though grouped query attention uh is it
has more activation memory than
multiquery when with these large models
it's still not a much larger it's not a
much larger it's still a smaller
proportion of what you're doing in the
fe4 sure line right so I guess three
things like ignore make it really make
it really big uh second is I guess you
you by the even the uh with prolong
context you can you can do some of the
the some of these approaches that you
talked about but then then you also have
these system optimizations which are
pretty cool um it so the softmax has an
interesting property that you can
compute it an online fashion you can
compute it incrementally so if you've
got a if you've got if you've got a
bunch of Logics you're kind of streaming
them if you've got a partial if you've
got a partial softmax and a new logic
comes in you can update it you can
update it on online fashion right so
what does that mean that means that now
you never needed to write logits or the
P into the hbm so you save a lot right
if there's an extremely long sequences
you end up writing a lot so you you save
on that and and both these approaches
end up uh in one case the first paper
was on tpus that introduced this this uh
introduced this property or or took
advantage of this property is on the
property to be able to compute the
softmax in an online fashion and the
second paper which is now flash
attention today um they've had they've
had many advancements they actually had
some systems level optimization where
they they they now you can actually have
very very long sequences on uh on on
gpus the optimizations of gpus by by
basically not not not moving the loit
back into hbm using this online using
this property and also I me writing the
right corns that use theam and
everything use the GP any with any
questions uh what's the
time
so we are basically 20 minutes more so
I'll finish in 10 uh so so I just
covered these two you know there's
there's many many there's I guess
there's there's other important
improvements um you know I'd say so we
talked about the pre pre and post versus
post layer Norm there's been some
there's been some changes of the feed
forward layers themselves like you can
you can you can stare at the feed
forward layers I mean you sted anything
long enough everything becomes ATT
tension but it's true in the feed
forward case that if you look at it you
can sort of think about them as it looks
like attention and there's a paper that
sort of uh like turned that into a bit
like turn that turn those into memories
it was originally by Facebook I actually
forget what it was but it didn't it like
the the feed for layers just stay I mean
we typically haven't seen a lot of
improvements on them um there have been
some i i i there have been some efforts
on higher order attention right now
attentionally if you think about it as a
third order interaction you have queries
keys and values but uh and right now but
but you could imagine actually having
four order interactions where you're
actually Computing lits of pairs of
things against all pairs of things right
so these are now higher order
interactions where now you can have
complicated like geometries that you
actually include in your uh include in
your attention computation and maybe
it's important for say biology or some
biology but it's not been explored much
um what has actually worked and as
likely to N St as some approaches on
passor decoding not quite the original
less or non-auto regressive aspirations
that we had but these more speculative
decoding where the heris stic there is
pretty simple yeah you score if you want
you instead of generating from a heavy
model generate from a really light model
that captures the diversity then score
with a heavy model so then you then you
rerank the list and that ends up working
quite well and most most most State most
um production deployments likely use
speculative decoding um okay so now
switching Switching gears I guess you
know we start we started we started this
uh we started this or we started we
started by you know quoting the the
Dartmouth conference where they wanted
to build a single machine and and and
the question now is with large language
models that are now eating up most of
the internet uh are we getting are we
quite getting there and and and we are
seeing some remarkable we're finally
seeing self-supervised learning work at
a scale that work at an unprecedented
scale where you with now by by by like
digesting carefully curated and colossal
amounts of text with very very large
models you're able to then they're able
to perform presumably or still waiting
to be confirmed like tasks that are that
tasks that are that are or they able to
actually perform at least a large a
broad variety of tasks by just
specifying them in the prompt and and
and it's now it's almost like now you
have now you have a new computer and for
people here who are really excited about
the future of Agents now they can
program thousands of Agents with the
same computer oh maybe you now they have
now they have now they have agents that
they can several agents that they can
program with the same computer then that
then coordinate to solve problems so I I
we're getting we're much closer to this
single model not quite being able to
specify all the rules of intelligence
but at least learning all the rules from
data we're very close to very we're much
closer to it than we were before now
this doesn't include all the important
thing the all the important um uh
specialization that has to happen after
like RF or the the the alignment that
you have to do the to make them aut most
steerable right but it's and and and and
and and as it stands today the scaling
laws that the Transformer exhibits are
better than any other existing model
right there's an interesting question of
you
know which can we build a better model
and there are efforts there's I guess
from from the Stanford from Chris Chris
Chris R lab there have been a couple of
efforts uh there's been some Revival of
RNN but I think only the only the only
thing I'll say that is that the
attention operation itself this
operation of actually moving information
around or routing information based on
content is is very very useful and and
it's maybe not a surprise that this
General sort of spatial mixing up
upsampling down sampling architecture
has kind of stayed both in Vision
computer vision and language now with
the Transformer so there are some
invariants that are likely to say but I
I do think that maybe that and and there
is certainly much more room there to
improve I mean not just in the
architecture but on data itself like
there probably 2x improvements on on
data uh but I I I wouldn't say that
there's there aren't architectur in the
future that'll get better scaling laws
they kind they might but there are
properties about the Transformer such as
self attention and its General
structuring that is likely that that
likely we're going to see in future
architectures to come um also it's hard
to really think of a a sing modern like
if if you if somebody really really
wanted to study lar scale modern
Transformers you'd have to study like
you know all reducers infin band Rocky
and what like whether you get conest and
you have very very large clusters uh so
it's it's interesting and so the
computer is know the computer the
Transformers is now in some sense a data
center because it's not split up these
large Transformers or with tens of
potentially tens of thousands of gpus so
um uh and and and so if you so so now
you actually have to really focus on
several parts the
infrastructure and and the model itself
but what's really interesting I think is
you know I was just thinking of the
smallest model that has exhibited
emergent phenomena well so we certainly
know that gp4 which is likely uh I don't
know if you're allowed to say some big
like trillion parameters yeah I think
say yeah it's it's a trillion parameter
size model that's what everybody says
size model and then you have grocking
which is a two layer Transformer that
has this weird emerg being weird
emergent behavior that when you just
keep training it on just on some amount
of data suddenly it just exhibits a
spaces shift right so we're lucky there
these like really there's strange
there's weirdness everywhere there's
weirdness in small models and large
models and and and maybe that and maybe
we can learn something about a large
models by studying these smaller models
one would hope but it's funny like
there's there's there's still
unexplained phenomena in very very large
models and very very small models but
large Transformers are no more just you
know like a cab there's just I mean it's
still could still be but it's you have
to there's so many there there's so much
that you have to to keep in your stack
in order to really optimize this entire
this this model um of course some of the
very exciting directions are llm using
llms using tools you that's so now now
the now the benefits of now now language
models of Transformers are actually
starting to use external entities so
they're connecting with the rest of the
world and and and I guess that's a
that's a good that's a good pitch for it
it makes a lot of sense to to actually
build products today because it's
through interactions with like if you
want to get to the next trunch of
capabilities where will they come from
and and likely with a lot of usage you
will learn much more about how to guide
these models and how to train them
without then in then in vacuum now you
can definitely do very very important
work still in in in in by by even with a
smaller model or or even without
building a product without building a
product because there's so many
important unsolved problems uh and and
uh maybe you shouldn't even work on the
Transformer because it's like burning
man right now everybody's going to the
same party but um but um but I I think
that you will you will be able to build
new capabilities once these once with
this human human machine collaboration
um of course you know teaching models I
me or models being able to express what
they don't know uh how do you learn new
skills at infants time important for
there's an interesting work I think on
um Minecraft that showed some evidence
of this is also important for agents and
another great property that uh some of
these diffusion models have is the more
compute you spend the potentially better
the quality of the image gets but we
don't exactly quite have that for
language can and and what does that mean
like so today the best the models that
can reason that have the most proficient
reasoning uh and planning are also the
largest ones can we can we separated it
out can we have smaller models that do
some adaptive thinking and have are able
to match the capabilities of potentially
larger models and reasoning and planning
and maybe the answer is going to come by
connecting to external planners and
planners or or or maybe with better
representations of data you can actually
reason better on it um also um this is
again a more systems systems piece but
it's fascinating how low you can
actually get on your how how how how how
low you can uh how few bits you can
actually use and still get something
useful out we already went from the
original Transformer was was train on
32bit Precision then we went to B FL 16
and now there's good signs that inate
and fp8 would work and I think there's
useful work to be done there again going
back to the same you know this this
argument about if if if you're actually
if you're if the if you're Vector if
you're using fewer bits to represent a
number you're actually transmitting
fewer bits to the to from hbm so
actually you can you can get faster you
utilize the you can utilize your your
Matrix multipliers much more effectively
um that that was it so it's many topics
but hopefully covered something fun
thank
you
yeah could you talk about what working
on now and yeah yeah so um so U I'm a
co-founder at a startup with uh with my
with with my transform coor Nikki and
we're working on uh we're working on
building uh building models that'll
that'll ultimately uh automate workflow
and we're starting with data so um it's
very puzzling what happen in a company
and companies are just basically just
masses of dark knowledge right and and
there's very few people that have that
both the technical privilege and uh the
understanding to ask questions like an
typically analysts but the less you
understand the less effective your
company can be so how can you eventually
help anyone become an an effective
analyst in some sense right so help them
ask the right question help them figure
out eventually they wise which then
requires some kind of counterfactual
reasoning that's fairly complicated but
start with start with data since it's so
important and and companies are
essentially drowning in it and then then
can be spread out from there and then
try to automate other workflows in the
in press but we believe that some of the
like the early signs that receive and
what and our position is that um I I
believe that this is going to require
full stack approach so not just uh
building the building the model because
you can then control what feedback you
give and so if you have a gap in the
model you ask for that you kind of you
aspire to get that feedback so then you
can improve the model that's that's what
that's what we're doing
yeah please talk talk to
us yeah I'm surprised to hear that
you're fairly bullish about tools in the
end like third party things we talked
about in the beginning that your
motivation was Transformers enabled us
to get rid of pipelines but I feel
likees again so I'm surprised can you
talk about
that right right so so so I mean so
until we get to the point of where it's
like you know where Turtles all the way
down it's like Transformers all the way
way down no I I don't I think that tool
just allows you to inter so it's kind of
like how do you interface with a machine
that can really like that can think
right yeah you have to build some kind
of interface and if you build a useful
functionality you want the machine to be
able to take your functionality and and
do General useful things with it right I
think that using tools is just a way of
leveraging leveraging things that people
have built and software out there
certain tools will probably get absorbed
in the model right some others won't and
and that still gives us the ability to
like yeah it still gives us the ability
to to like and certain things that
Transformers shouldn't even do sorry I
mean like like you don't want to spend a
billion flops per position to calculate
two numbers right you don't want to
spend more flops by to do an operation
that required like one billion to the
flops right so there's certain things
that the model should not do it should
use external it should use external
tools and uh the certain things that the
the certain certain certain kind of
thinking that the model should do so
even from a capability perspective
there's an important question of what
all capability should be in this neural
network right and but then also being
able to utilize the work that other
others have done software that other
people have
yeah you talks more about why like the
original approach of you know decoding
parall andely refining it yeah something
why that didn't work and what yeah so
sometimes if you know exactly why things
work maybe you can make it work but um
it ended up being so you're able to do
silly things like randomly sort which
means that somebody walks up to you with
the uh sequence and you know you can I
mean you can break two modes like you
can say ascending or descending kind so
or how do how do I say this so typically
when you decode right imagine that uh
you when you when you give a prompt you
have many possible completions right and
each time you make a choice you you you
you you you narrow that space and each
time another choice you narrow that
space right so and and and you have a
very and you've learned to narrow the
the the set of all possible in some
sense paths in in a in a way the model
doesn't have to decide what's the order
in which you have to do it right when
you're kind of when you're doing this
less or non autor regressive generation
you have to do both right and doing
learning both simultaneously is hard it
end I mean but eventually I think that
if for a
particular I think this is probably true
right if if an Oracle walked up to me
and said this is the order in which all
these sentences should be generated
first you should generate these three
words then you should generate these
other two than these other two if
somebody walked up you and gave you this
Oracle ordering for all of human
language I think we would have a much
better chance and you could actually get
this less not autoaggressive generation
at least working what were the two
things you said so one was uh so one so
one thing was basically the ordering
itself and I think it kind of has to do
that because the ordering helps you then
lock down the modes it NS down what
you're going to generate next so
ultimately I think it does boil down to
what's the right not autor regressive
ordering and that could be either you're
still generating one word at a time but
not Auto aggressively or you're
generating a few and then based on that
you're generating the other few so like
the words that so the words that you can
generate a once should be conditionally
independent of each other right like
what you generated so far should have
completely explained them and then what
you generate after should again be they
should be they should be condition
independent right so how do you learn
these condition independences yeah and
if somebody walked up me and gave them
to me I think we probably learn they
probably learned them
yeah
uh question it's
more like
recently more
of and I think more of his thinking is
that only like scaring small spot
doesn't help them to actually learn like
what how the real world actually work
and
have a good idea of like trth and yeah
and real world General yeah do you agree
with him do
you areound
this um so yeah I think it's interesting
like how how you can learn a world model
with just language right um so I mean
some of these models are not exactly
being learned that way you're doing rlf
you're giving some feedback so which
means there's some you're you're you're
applying some uh they are modifying
themselves to to some preference right
so there's so it's not just just a pure
language model but it's interesting so
you've SE some of the workl robotics is
now potentially starting to flourish
because they're able to use these large
models as planners right and so I I
think that it's it's it's surprising how
much of the world how much information
about the world that they carry and if I
understand is that is that right that
the say canw work basically use the
language model now as a planner yeah
right and then they left the rest of it
to just the standard perception and and
and and and and the classical pass you
soling in robotics so that's I mean that
that's now while it's Jan is probably
still right but the usefulness of it is
evident in something that needs World
Knowledge right so I think you can do a
lot with what you have um I
mean
uh they probably yeah I mean it's we
still haven't quite EXP extracted all
these out of these models what and and
it might be right simultanous but there
still a lot more to be
yeah um so I'm similar to the previous
question and you're also talking about
like imers right um I'm just curious to
know like like what your thoughts are
more on like generalizability and imers
especially in the like I know there was
like a paper from Deep mind about like
the yeah I think yeah like they can't
really generalize outside of like what
they' trained on like especially because
these large models now that they're just
trained on everything like is there
truly anything left that's out of
distribution that you really sort of
Benchmark it on so I I have been caught
saying that if I had all my test and my
training i' would make a billion dollars
yeah so I don't have a problem with with
it so but I still think so okay so so
correct me if I'm wrong but the general
argument is that uh these models have
learned such a vast set of distributions
and phenomena that typically when you
interrogate them they're often very you
know very cleverly blending or bringing
bringing information from what they've
learned right um it it might yes and and
then they have these algorithmic tasks
where they where the models St able to
generalize right so I'll focus on the
the I'll focus on the on the former I
think that that's an incredibly useful
property
it might be that so I think maybe the
failing is that we actually don't quite
understand how much we could how much is
even represented in text and second how
much how much how far we could go if we
were able to blend information from
different from different uh like
certainly being able to write about the
Stanford this lecture in the in the
rhyme meter and words of Cher is not
possible because nobody did it right but
I think that you could do it right now
is that blending from what you already
have if so that's that's a that means
you can that's that's an incredible
that's an incredible skill right um
yeah I haven't read it it's very recent
but I I believe the work I think you can
show that these models generaliz but I
think there's a surprising amount of
like uh new seemingly new things you
could do by just blending information
from what you've already learned on the
inter and and yeah largely probably has
to do that there's so much other yeah
yeah um so you question yeah I had
questions
ago I think I had an ordering in mind
and then it came back yeah sorry um but
uh give me a
second I was wondering who might have
inside connecting different agents
Transformers or what not you know you're
a Transformer is essentially like a
great connection neurons in specific way
and it's awesome right like so you you
figured out the best way to connect them
so far AG no the neurons oh the neurons
you're talking about do Som to do in the
brain no like the neurons in the
Transformer right like the transformer
is the the the way you connect you know
different pieces together and then when
you connect everything together that
works form I was wondering if you have
some insights into the building system
that connect and you know perform the
best together yeah
is not goingon to like this I like to
make this joke the best agents are
actually because they can communicate
with each other they can update
themselves really really well but what
the other agents are doing um what is
the fundamental Problem by making what
is the fundamental issue in making a
bunch of uh bunch of bunch of I'm trying
to understand what are the fundamental
problems and trying to make a bunch of
systems work together that's what you're
asking one is goal DEC composition right
and one is the second big one is
coordination and third one is
verification like if you solved a
successful decomposition of the goals
based on what this what your estimate of
the skills of these agents are if you
able to what they've done and if you if
you're able to coordinate then I think
you could make a lot of progress right
so while I didn't answer your question I
don't know in general how much we've how
much progress we've made in this in all
in these three areas but does somebody
have any input
here
par and you have something that's
man each the job
andess and everything
andig
almost everything and time and
it's like how you break how
you like
yeah problems are
probably maybe to
some
but human
modity like phenomena like you need some
special to that happen yeah and by
modularity here you mean that is it is
it modularity in that they they have
this this region has this this
responsibility or even is the
composition different the construction
the the construction different what do
you mean by that because you one you
could have both You could argue that
there's no the responsibility is
diffused across the model mixtures of
experts tries to go in the opposite
direction which I but I I should have
probably mentioned that's another really
exciting Direction which is which it
happened to the three4 years and it's
going to stti right I totally missed it
uh that kinds of tries to get the
specialization right so maybe that is
some kind of modularity right learn
modularity um the rest is the rest of
responsibility performing the task is
likely distributed but if now you're
going to these subsystems themselves of
different composition then you kind of
get back to like uh and and I know that
the like this was a goal with the
pathways project at Google where you
wanted to have these really modular
systems communic with each other and I
think
there's it's just taken so long to get
gradiant descent like descent in fact
sometimes I think that Building
architecture to sort of gr descent and
and and uh feel like it's if you can if
you can learn with gr descent it's very
useful uh if maybe it's actually
possible to make these modular systems
work we have some of it through experts
and uh I'd imagine some of these
problems that be discussed does that
does that make sense
sorry circling back to now whatever
seven questions ago you mentioned that
the problem with deting all at once was
one of the things that Cod gener has
this assumption that the outputs areally
independent but aren't they in the sense
that if you have a l space if you're
given the lightning space as your prior
then your posterior outputs should be
conditionally independent each other
right uh so great point and and where do
you get the from well from the from from
the encoder what I the beginning right
this might be like quite a few W to
translate something right yeah there's a
multiple so if there's only one mode
then yeah it's prob right but if there's
like multiple ways of uh well I show
this two things how much does the Laten
space actually carry by an important to
ask right how much does it actually
carry because it's not just late one L
Vector that you're transmitting every
you're you're doing attention again and
again but
but we took this approach where we did
precisely this we we Auto agressively
generated uh we Auto agressively
generated tokens in a new vocabulary
using vectro quantization so the the
conditional dependence was modeled in a
latent space where we discretized using
elector quantization and then based on
that we we generated everything
conditioning everything and that did
work but uh again uh so so that did work
uh in Translation uh the issue there
were some funky issues there where it
the latent the latent uh sequence of
latent vectors were only effective not
effective if you learn directly on the
original data you had to do something
like distillation because distillation
itself throws away potentially some of
the modes so generally lower entry data
was we were we had to train on it the
second piece was for practical systems
you have to make the whole thing really
really fast but this is a good this was
a good research exercise but ultimately
it didn't have the right practic
because speculative decoding practically
with what we have right
work yeah yeah exactly yeah but you're
right I think if you can generate if you
can generate sufficiently if you can
generate a good sufficient latency then
yes you're right we can assume that that
makes everything conditionally
independent then yeah and we managed to
do that a bit managed to do that but it
wasn't quite good
enough I guess this is the last
question person
question wow that's too personal yeah
very personal uh and and uh I have I
have friends there they're all really
great they're doing incredible things
um I think that there's we'll be
surprised how much there is to do and if
so first the motivation right there is
an entire new well there's an entire new
uh bucket of or like a like new trunch
of capabilities that you will get with
human computer interaction so you can
make a product people use it they give
you feedback models get smarter and this
and this this close this clo loop system
can can really bring in really Advanced
models and and and bring value right
that's one um second um yeah I think
it's helpful to have some the Deep
learning benefited so much from A
diversity ideas and people producing
people people pursuing important
directions I would say the same about uh
I would say the same about uh building I
mean products as well or building you
know building uh companies that are
building new kinds of products with
these models right so I would say that
we have there's there's so much surface
area that uh we could we could we could
do something incredible so that's second
is third you know yeah want to maybe
that's that's the more person that I
just want to do think
yeah